depression is increasing among teenagers
in the United States shuddhi studies
show that more than three million
adolescents struggle with it
60% did not receive the treatment that
they needed the stigma surrounding
mental health often prevent open
discussions and as part of our effort to
keep conversations about mental health
at the forefront mark Strassmann spoke
to one Georgia family about their
journey out of darkness will Hagen was
17 and carrying a secret only he knew he
said hey mom can we talk Tracy Hagen
thought her all-american high school
junior was feeling typical teenage
stress but then when he said I'm
depressed
I mean I'm seriously depressed and have
been for a long time that blew me away
he was upbeat he was getting up every
day he was involved in his activities so
it was confusing and I'm thinking what's
he talking about I'm depressed but your
first reaction was denial not for him
but for you yes yes yes like this can't
be I would know but will says he has
felt blue since he was nine joy really
wasn't there much it wasn't that I
started to become sad more off and I
just started to become apathetic what
did you tell your mom I simply told her
look for as long as I can remember I've
been very depressed it was a lot of
unknown to me
so trying to describe it to her was
difficult but I knew that this wasn't
normal and I knew that I was miserable
it's estimated more than three million
US children aged 12 to 17 have at least
one major depressive episode a year
that's about one in eight adolescents
for years you just swallowed it since I
was nine I just thought I need to figure
this out myself
when Hargens opened up about his
depression his mother realized her next
words mattered so I said to him thank
you so much for telling me thank you for
trusting me I can tell this is really
hard for you I just want you to know
we're gonna be here for you from here on
out you're not on your own a brain is a
bigger bully Kim Kirkup a licensed
professional counselor treated will for
about eight months
the Hargens gave us permission to
talk to her what is it they did it right
by realizing that you know whenever
somebody's depressed you have to act if
you if it drags on for too long it just
it's just going to exacerbate everything
will says he never felt suicidal before
telling his mother but had you not told
her or had her response been unhelpful
could you have sunk even lower that was
a moment where things have gotten
significantly better or far worse very
quickly will is now 19 and a student at
Bentley University in Massachusetts his
freshman class was asked to write a
one-sentence personal statement on their
arm called dear world
I wrote the phrase I can feel the
daylight again on my forearm right here
essentially saying I'm out of the
darkness I can actually feel things
again and I can enjoy the daylight when
you first saw it yeah I broke down
because when I saw it he was standing
there so powerfully so just in his own
being he's telling all these strangers
his story and he's telling them I'm
better something to think about if
someone close to you says can we talk
for CBS this morning
mark Strassmann Roswell Georgia these
conversations are so important you ask
you if you've had a kid you know go
through depression or anxiety talking
about it I mean it helps it enormous
yeah I think that story's gonna resonate
with so many this morning and talk about
what they did right certainly will felt
safe telling his mother that's what I
keep hearing they have to feel safe to
talk to you and that you were open to
hearing it without judgment it's a [ __ ]
and she listened yes I'm so glad you
have no stigma attached right stigma
attached to that all you want for your
kids is them to be happy
yeah and they took action and saw a
professional because you need
professional help yeah this isn't
something you can do by yourself you're
right about that very very very
important for me thanks
mark to mark Strassmann indeed and will
and his mom this is bargain thank you
all